hi I'm Erik Bosse and a benchers
infinity war has released yet another
trailer this time a shorter one titled
chant and boy oh boy it is getting tough
to watch this infinity war footage
without the threat of self spoilage even
though the directors of this movie sent
out a letter begging us to stay silent
Marvel Studios apparently missed that
memo because this trailer has lots of
pretty huge reveals so yeah boiler
warning in case any of these miscible
details I'm about to get to in depicts
imposing too much as I tell my
co-workers who complain that my casual
Friday shorts are too short you don't
have to look okay to start off a lot of
these shots this trailer we're already
in past trailers go check out my
breakdowns for the stuff that you missed
in these but for now let's take a look
at the new stuff first there's this shot
of thanasis cue ship hovering over
Manhattan we saw the same shot in the
last trailer but now this edit includes
a cloud of destruction that the ship is
causing in the city below if you look
closely this cloud features an orangish
glow with a band of light moving across
it now we're still trying to figure out
exactly what this ship does but this
band makes it seem like it's creating
some kind of barrier over this region
maybe trying to isolate it for terra
formation or maybe even suck these
blocks out of the city and telephone him
somewhere else moving on we get this
reunion between cap and Bucky where
their view of the end-times takes the
form of some gallows humor the world I
like how Bucky's eyes glanced over to
T'Challa as if to thank him for helping
him recover in this Kingdom after the
events of civil war next there are these
epic shots of black panther shouting
this warrior chant amongst his army now
you may remember a similar champ in the
movie black panther I believe Nakia says
it well T'Challa fights in Baku and
warrior Falls they're saying a Bombay
which actually is a real-life meaning
the spoken language of Wakanda is based
on the real world language of Xhosa
spoken in South Africa and according to
various translators at a fan on line the
Bombay can be a standalone word or a
part of a couple phrases including
Bombay Amandla which roughly translates
to hold fast and yeah sorry for the
probable mispronunciation of those hold
fast is derived from an old nautical
term that direct sailors to hold tightly
to a ship's rigging as they head into a
storm or battle so bringing in this
real-life historical and cultural
context is really one of the things that
made black panther so great excited to
see it come back into a findi war here
moving on there's this shot of Thanos
arriving
datian makes it look like Wakanda this
shot is the most talked about of this
trailer in this YouTube widescreen
aspect ratio the framing cuts off
Thanos's Infinity Gauntlet but but but
in the square version released on
Instagram and Twitter you can see the
bottom of the gauntlet and for the first
time in any of this footage Thanos has
at least four Infinity stones now in
addition to the purple Power Stone and
the blue space stone he now has the red
reality stone and the one we've been
wondering so much about the orange stole
stone and it's hard to tell if he has
the green time stone on the thumb I'm
guessing not I think the bulk of
Infinity Ward will feature Thanos
seeking the mind stone from vision in a
time stone from Doctor Strange so we can
assume that Thanos acquired the reality
stone from elsewhere in the cosmos it
was last seen in the ether form left
with the collector in nowhere meanwhile
the origin of the soul stone remains a
mystery actually check out the numerous
videos I made for various thoughts on
that but I think we can safely say it's
not on earth like inside the vibranium
meteorite in Wakanda or inside cap
somehow like that US is arriving to
earth here and be a little weird if it
was on earth somewhere else also notice
how the moment that he appears through
this rift in space these space stone
glows while the other three don't so I'm
thinking this is what it looks like when
Thanos chooses to activate the abilities
of one of the stones so that whole
standoff with cap and the last trailer
neither the space nor the Power Stone
glowed in that moment maybe that's why
cap was able to resist him it was only
Thanos's brute strength he was competing
with okay next there's this overhead
shot of Falcon and Bucky actually
matches the angle of the shot from the
last trailer with Black Widow and banner
in war machine I'm guessing in this part
of the same scene with all these guys
looking up at the arrival of thanasis
forces then in the trailer there are two
interesting new shots of Black Widow
first there's this one mid battle notice
how the wakandan soldiers behind her
appear to be getting back to their feet
dazed looks like they were all knocked
to their feet but now natasha sees some
second wave coming in now i'll get to
the second black widow shot in a second
but first a quick thanks to our sponsor
vikings war of clans it's an amazing
mobile game where you can live as a
Viking and raid and wage war on other
Vikings all over the world it's great
fun fact DNA studies claim that one out
of 30 people is a direct descendant of
the Viking warriors and since we have
over 1.2 million subs here at new
rockstar
there's at least 400,000 Vikings amongst
us right now so join me in 20 million
Vikings in the most epic battle of the
month on mobile use my links in the
description below download Vikings war
of clans and get 200 gold an initial
protection shield and your place in
Valhalla yeah obviously I'm really into
this and you can actually find me in the
game at new rock stars underscore Eric
okay back to the trailer with the second
new shot of Black Widow look closely and
see that she's fighting Corvus glaive
the leader of Thanos's Black Order he
swipes his deadly Glade over her head
and she counters with and this is
interesting this spear of Proxima
midnight
Corvus his wife this actually matches
the closeup of black widow driving in
this spear in the first trailer does
this mean Proxima has been defeated
it's her spear something the Avengers
are trying to steal or keep away from
the Black Order I've so many questions
then there's this quick shot of Shuri
spinning around and firing their
vibranium arm cannon almost as if it's a
surprise maybe this is how they disarm
Proxima then a new shot of Thanos jump
punching out of an explosion perhaps as
part of his bout with Iron Man and
Doctor Strange star-lord in spider-man
on Peggy there's also this shot of Hulk
roaring which is interesting because
it's the only time we've seen an on
banner Hulk in this footage aside from
that big marathon run shot that closed
out the first trailer which I have a
suspicion will not be in the final cut
of infinity Wars just to clean and
trailer 8 for me we'll see the lighting
in this new Hulk shot matches the other
shots we've seen of that as guardianship
location I think this could all be from
the beginning of the movie when Thanos
and the Black Order drop in on Thor Loki
and Hulk on the as guardianship but they
were on at the end through a Ragnarok to
get the space stone next there's a very
quick shot of Iron Man zipping through
the streets in New York as chaos reigns
around him these things look more
organized than falling rubble they look
more like appendages reaching out to
Janna this could be an effect of that
cue ship I pointed out earlier or maybe
Thanos is using the gauntlet to like
materialize rebel against Iron Man then
there's a new shot of Scarlet Witch in
battle waiting down our hands they glow
with red mystical energy did you see
that behind her neither a black widow
nor a coy a are attacking the outriders
surrounding them I'm assuming that
whatever Wanda is about to do will take
care of all these outriders for them the
trailer closes that with a little joke
to lighten the mood thank God with a
collie a telling T'Challa she expected
his open
okano to the world would mean hosting
the Olympics or Starbucks not all this
crazy crap but among that crap is one
last visible detail another battle with
a background explosion lighting up two
fighters on the left you can see Proxima
midnight with their spear but on the
right the red glow Scarlet Witch the
explosion itself was caused by this beam
on the left which looks like one of the
ones released by vision this location
matches that shot in the first trailer
that showed vision pinned down by Corvus
glaive and Proxima midnight they try to
claw the mine stone from his head
wherever Wanda and vision were camping
out at the beginning of that trailer it
looks like the Black Order has found
them not looking good for anybody so a
question for you guys
whom do you think will be the first to
die an infinity war I mean someone's
gonna die who's gonna be the first blood
comment down below with your thoughts or
tweet me directly at a loss and follow
new rockstars on Twitter for updates on
our videos like this video share it
around subscribe to new rock stars for
all of our infinity war deep dives hit
that little Bell icon to make sure
getting notified when our videos are
coming out but yeah guys everything you
know about the MCU we got it here I'm
gonna go take a cold shower thanks for
watching